investigators have been turning the
apartment in the small town upside down
they're looking for dangerous materials
and further clues as to what the couple
might have been planning police who
raided the home confiscated a bomb that
was ready for use
along with arms and ammunition officials
suspect the couple arrested a German
national and his Turkish wife are
Islamist extremists especially it's the
products thus we suspect that there is a
Salafist background to this according to
the police investigation so far we were
able to prevent a terrorist attack a
hardware store tipped off the police a
month ago the couple allegedly used
false identities to buy a large quantity
of hydrogen peroxide which can be used
to make bombs media reports say the man
is a chemist and has connections to the
Salafist seen in Frankfurt officials
have been watching him for weeks before
they moved in if he accused began acting
suspiciously while he was under
observation he spent time along the
route of the bicycle race that takes
place tomorrow in Frankfurt but that
bike race a popular annual event in
Frankfurt has now been cancelled it was
supposed to go right past the suspects
apartment
you